one and lift off
the rise of starliner and a new era in
human space flight
in 2019 boeing and nasa attempted to
send an uncrewed spacecraft to the
international space station
but the test flight failed to reach the
correct orbit
it was just one in a series of issues
the company's space program
has faced in recent years now as boeing
gears up to launch starliner again
all eyes are on the company if it
succeeds the test flight could renew
investor in customer confidence in
boeing's space
program but if it fails it could put a
dent in the already weakened
aerospace company so it's a big
challenge with very high stakes
and a lot of national and corporate
pride at stake
and a lot of money at stake here's how
boeing which was once the gold standard
of the stars
got to this point for decades
boeing was at the cutting edge of the
space industry they've been
involved in every major nasa development
this is steven genoate
a space industry veteran who's consulted
in the industry for 15 years
they built critical communication
satellites for nasa
and for others in the commercial and the
national security industry
in 2014 boeing was awarded a nasa
contract
worth as much as 4.2 billion dollars but
just four years later
an external audit found that the world's
largest aerospace company
was struggling in october 2018 at the
direction of congress
nasa released an audit of its space
launch system
also known as the sls this deep space
explorer
is the most powerful rocket nasa has
ever developed and is one of the
agency's largest contracts with boeing
nasa's audit found that the project was
years behind schedule
and billions of dollars over budget due
in part to management
technical and infrastructure issues
driven by boeing's poor performance
what the auditor's report did was was
surfaced to the space division some of
the the engineering challenges that seem
to have
seeped throughout the company both its
broader defense
and commercial jetliner business doug
cameron has covered boeing
and the larger aerospace and defense
industry for over 30 years
he explains that as the development of
the space launch system continued
boeing was juggling another high-profile
contract with nasa
as well the commercial crew program
which aims to send astronauts and cargo
to and from the international space
station inside of boeing's starliner
crew capsule
boeing was the original prime contractor
and integrator for the international
space station so they helped design and
implement that from inception
and they still help to operate the space
station and being able to bring
astronauts up on a boeing capsule
to the station is something that boeing
has set out as a major goal for its
space program
when starliner launched in december 2019
it was a critical moment for boeing but
just minutes into the test flight
nasa's controllers knew something had
gone wrong
so we did have obviously some challenges
today
when the when the spacecraft separated
from the launch vehicle
we did not get the orbital insertion
burn that we were hoping for
the spacecraft's internal timer was off
by 11 hours
stranding it in the wrong orbit which
prevented it from being able to reach
the international space station the
failure in 2019 of the on-orbit test of
starliner was driven
primarily due to faulty software
and maybe more importantly faulty
software testing
boeing chose to design tests in a way
that were not truly representative or
tied to the actual
vehicle itself and these mistakes were
costly
boeing has taken a 410 million dollar
charge primarily to run a second test
this is about 10 percent of the
program's entire budget
a boeing spokesperson said that since
the first test flight the company has
made important changes to the software
code that are consistent with the
recommendations of the boeing
nasa independent review team so i think
boeing is invested in this
both with its brand as a
as a great and historic engineering
company
that has been serving nasa since its
inception
but also financially because boeing as
we all know
overall is in much more difficult
financial circumstances due to pandemic
and problems with their commercial
aircraft
and that puts an even higher spotlight
on the performance of starliner
since starliner's orbital failure in
2019
boeing's space program has faced a
series of additional challenges
in 2020 federal prosecutors opened a
criminal probe
into whether a senior nasa official
improperly told a boeing executive about
the status of a lunar lander contract
causing the company to change its bid
boeing ultimately lost the contract
to competitors and in january 2021 the
company faced another setback
when the main engines for the space
launch system shut down prematurely
during a ground test
these problems are to be expected that's
why you do the testing the problem for
boeing is it's the latest in a series of
very high profile failures
and obviously have customers and boeing
investors
asking the question you know when will
they get it right
but despite years of issues and wavering
faith from nasa
boeing has seen successes in the space
industry as well
it's a 50 50 partner in the united
launch alliance
a company which has successfully
launched over 140 consecutive missions
more than any other launch program in
the world boeing has also developed
satellites
spacesuits and other technology for nasa
and continues to play a key role
in the maintenance of the international
space station for boeing the space
program
is a key part of the company it's part
of its defense space and security unit
boeing's largest by revenue after a
sharp drop in aircraft deliveries over
the past two years
with travel demand still weak due to the
pandemic
experts say boeing will likely continue
to rely on the unit
this is one reason all eyes are on the
company's next test launch
of starliner the spacecraft's second
uncrewed flight
was slated for march but has been pushed
back due to scheduling and repair delays
for boeing the pressure is on the
company is already far behind
competitor spacex which has successfully
launched astronauts to the iss
as part of nasa's commercial crew
program the entire industry will be
looking at boeing who's already named
astronauts that it would like to fly and
those astronauts are ready and waiting
to go up on a boeing vehicle
but boeing needs to make sure that
vehicle is safe
it needs to make sure that not only all
of the mechanical and
normal challenges are addressed but all
of the software and the software testing
and oversight challenges
have been addressed and have been
managed by the company if the launch is
a success
astronauts could be flying to the
international space station inside
boeing's starliner
later this year this would be a big win
for boeing at large
the company's ceo david calhoun said
that boeing was proud of all the
products and services
our engineers have developed and
delivered to our commercial and military
customers
over these last difficult years and of
the meaningful progress we are making in
safety
transparency and quality the success or
failure of starliner
will help determine the future of boeing
and its role in the exploration
and commercialization of outer space